[Music]
hey everybody welcome to planet coaster
college I know the title of this video
seems a little bit clique Betty but
trust me it is definitely not I'm
actually going to be talking about a
special technique using which you can
make your coasters much more smooth and
realistic than with any other way the
only thing is though I'm going to give a
quick warning it's a method that takes a
lot of time to do for some simple decent
sized coasters it might actually take
you hours to make a coaster this way and
also it's not a method that I came up
with it's something that Dustin or you
might know him as Kyle Sloane came up
with quite a while ago actually and I
have to give full credit to him it's
just something that barely anybody else
has ever done before and I think it's
time that more of the community
basically sees how you can make coasters
in another way as well so how does this
technique work and why should you use it
basically the technique boils down to
something very simple you have to make
your entire coastal layouts out of 4
meter long pieces and then smooth out
all the pieces separately multiple times
by selecting four pieces at the same
time I know that sounds a bit weird so
I'll explain it more throughout this
video of course but essentially what
you're doing is breaking the game
mechanics because the game has a good
coaster builder in fact it's a really
great coaster builder but it doesn't
have a hard line or continuous roll and
as someone who wants to make clothes as
realistic as possible or if you just
want to make a recreation of a coaster
that is accurate as possible it's really
annoying to have to work with the lack
of a hard line or a continuous roll on
roller coasters because these are
actually very important elements in
making kosis realistic so as a quick
explanation for those of you who don't
know what I'm talking about hard line is
the line that the coaster rolls around
when it goes through inversions or
through banked curves basically a
coaster track doesn't Bank around its
own axis but it banks around where the
heart of the riders is
relocated which makes them a lot more
smooth and that's also why for example
if you look at barrel rolls from the
front like this you see a big spiral
that's pretty important in making smooth
closers also various continuous roll and
this is probably better explained by
taking a picture or taking a quick video
of a coaster in game which doesn't have
continuous roll and what it means is
that there's a lack of a roll that keeps
on smoothly going what happens is that
every time the coaster or the tank
reaches the end of a track piece in
planet coaster the banking sort of slows
down for a little bit so if you look for
example at this inline twist or barrel
roll which we have over here you can see
that at 90 degrees at 180 degrees and
270 degrees the banking kind of slows
for a minute it's kind of like the
rolling is halted every now and then
instead of the roll being smooth so
these are two pretty important things
that you're going to keep in mind if you
want to make realistic coasters and that
are very much impossible to do in planet
coaster because of the smoothing tool
getting rid of your heart line and also
the lack of a continuous roll in planet
coaster
so yeah ending these elements through
coasters should make them a lot more
realistic and smooth and as far as I
know
using this 4 meter method is the only
method to come close to realistic
hardline and continuous roll that said
it still breaks your game it's
definitely not the way that you're
supposed to do it which is of course
also kind of proven by the fact that it
takes hours to do it and it also doesn't
work in every case that you might need
it for and it creates some weird glitchy
movements as well if you look for
example in the back car of a train you
can see all the cars in front of it kind
of jittery that said it works very well
for the nose POV and if you just look at
a coaster from offer.i chills as you can
kind of tell from the shots that I'm
showing here it's actually really smooth
if you look at some of these curves some
of these inversions especially looking
down the inversion down the drop here
it's a lot more smooth and anything you
can do
with regular track pieces that are
longer since you can see for example the
coast is really rotating around the hard
line it has a smooth continuous roll and
if you look for example at some of the
curves some of the banking it's very
smooth as well and even there you can
see that it's spanking around the car
instead of the car just being thrown to
the side because of the track banking
suddenly so yeah without further ado
let's get into the game and show you how
to do this technique and build a coaster
this way so for the sake of this
tutorial I'll be building a small hybrid
wooden coaster so I don't really have to
work on to larger coaster and I can
spend most of my time actually
explaining how you can use this method
to make a smooth coaster and something
that's really important to keep in mind
here is to turn on the banking offsets
this is how we're going to introduce
hardliner into the coaster and by
building the entire coast out of these 4
meter long pieces we're going to prevent
the smoothing tool from removing our
hardline because that's really one of
the biggest gripes the smoothing tool
removes hard lines if you've got large
pieces going on and even if you set the
banking offset very high smooth out the
coaster enough and your height line is
completely gone so that's something that
we're trying to prevent here and
basically what we just want to do is
roughly build our entire coaster layout
using these 4 meter long pieces it's
something that I always want to keep in
mind here is to exaggerate the shape a
little bit because this moving tool will
still get rid of some things slightly so
it will make your banking slightly less
and it will make your helix is slightly
smaller for example even if it's just
very mild and also of course everything
looks very jagged and weird this way and
that's really just something that you
shouldn't pay too much attention to just
keep in mind that things are going to
look a little bit more smooth once we're
done with this moving part of building
right now you really just want to look
at how you want to build the layout
where you want the coaster track to go
and how you want the banking and the
inversions to be shaped so in my case
I'm building a 30 small hybrid coaster
and
in the last part of the layout here I've
sort of got that very small quick
section going on where it's very close
to the ground and very quick and going
through a lot of side twists and turns
and small airtime levels and in a few
seconds the coaster should be done and
I'll give you a quick real-time overview
of what it looks like all right now that
the easy stuff is done it's time to head
into the real trick and the thing that
makes building courses like this they've
such a tremendous amount of time but
just before that I want to quickly go
over the layouts and kind of explain why
the way that it looks is actually good
in slightly more detail because the most
important thing is that you want the
layout to generally follow the shaping
that you're going for so looking for a
few very good examples of that for
instance we've got a curve over here
which looks absolutely horrible at the
moment but you can see if you sort of
draw in line ignoring the smoothness you
can follow the general curve that it's
going to go and it's a little bit
exaggerated as well that's something I
would really have to emphasize as well
make it a bit more exaggerated in terms
of banking in terms of twists and how
tight the hills are then you really want
them to finally be because taking the
smooth tool over it is going to get rid
a little bit of the banking and
especially we've got them very tight
cables going like the one that I have
for example over here it's going to make
that a little bit more smooth and a
little bit more flat so don't be afraid
to make those kind of sections very
rough around the edges and really
accentuate all the curves and the holes
are supposed to be good there they will
be kind of smoothed out by the smoothing
tool alright so now to move on to the
actual trick which makes this method of
going coasters smoother than you can
normally achieve what you're going to
want to do is smooth out the entire
track eight times in a very interesting
way basically what you have to do is you
select four pieces of track hit the
smooth or button and then move up one
piece of junk just like that grab the
end and go beginning and move them up by
one piece sometimes if you've kind of
lost count I don't know how many pieces
you're actually selecting just go back
to the last piece and kind of come from
there this is to three or there we go
and you can pretty much continue on your
merry way to the next piece now once
you've done all of that and once you've
made your way through the entire track
by using that method and you've gotten
to the end of the track you're going to
have to repeat the same process but
backwards so you're going to starting
from the back basically grab four pieces
at a time it's a smooth button and move
back one piece and once you've done that
once you've gone back and forth with
that with that method you need to repeat
that process three other times you can
do it two times as well but doing it
three more times gives you is slightly
smoother result it is very slight
difference though that it's just
slightly less rental in it but basically
you have to do that recommended three
times so you go back and forth back and
forth back and forth and four last time
it's a fourth time back and forth and
once you've done that and depending on
your coaster layouts that can take from
one one hour up to a few hours you've
got a very smooth coaster and the
question is if it's really worth it to
go through that entire process because
it's very harsh to do it's just the sake
of this coaster I will try and put
myself through it with this coaster and
show you what the end result looks like
that's that yellow fruit or a grapefruit
is also a pretty good reference for what
this kind of method will give you in
terms of layout something to keep in
mind though is that you really want to
use this method between every fluid
section of your track and what I kind of
mean by that is that you have to do this
continuous back and forth between brake
runs or lift hills but you don't want to
include the list Hill so you don't want
to use this process on the lift itself
and you want to stop it right before you
hit a brake run and if for instance
you've got a brake run in the middle of
your coaster track I recommend splitting
the coaster up and first smoothing out
the first half of the coaster this way
and then smoothing out
the section after the Midway break run
after that separately but yeah let's go
into the time-lapse and show you what
this process looks like and it's it's
going to be pretty stupid all right so
here's time up spiritual me regretting
my life decisions and trying to smooth
out this entire coaster and you can
actually see that it is really being
much more smooth for every single time
that you go over it so this is the first
round and this is just going forward but
you can already tell that everything is
starting to look a bit more smooth and
it just keeps getting a little bit
better for every time that you go over
it and doing it four times in total as
in going back and forth four times is
probably just the right balance between
not doing it too much but at the same
time smoothing out quite nicely because
if you do it too much them is moving
tool will still get rid of too much of
your shaping as well now something that
I do want to say about this is that I
did some separates moving in some areas
where I needed that like just in that
curve as you can tell I was trying to
just optimize the banking a little bit
and give that some extra smoothing
sometimes you have these little areas
where your shape in either gets off a
little bit too much or it's still not
quite as smooth as the rest of the
coastering you can definitely just go
over those sections separately as long
as you are still smoothing them out with
four sections at a time
the only real other rule that I guess
I'd have to say is that you've got some
very very tight sections where a few
track pieces of four meters make a very
large point of the elements like for
example final little airtime here or
that very small curve in that case I I
was using a lot of smoothing using three
pieces at a time instead of four pieces
at a time since it's just a very small
section of the track that maneuvers very
quickly with just a few track pieces so
in those kinds of cases it's usually a
little bit better to grab three pieces
at the same time but yeah that's really
just fine-tuning the general method of
grabbing
or pieces at a time and going through
the drink like that it's something that
I still kept for the rest of building
this coaster so yeah this is basically
all the time that I have let's take a
quick in-game look again and see what
the coaster looks like all right so here
she goes and I think that's looking
reasonably smooth it's still a little
bit jittery in some places but most
places are just about as smooth as you
can get them especially this transition
right here and know why I just love that
part and you've seen all of these camera
angles already so I'll get through a POV
in a second but it is one of these
things where sometimes I do kind of feel
like it's worth it to put all of these
hours into a layout like this just
because it looks so good to watch the
car go through it although I do know
this last section is a little bit too
fast I kind of didn't want to trim it
because I just didn't want to add any
terms to the coaster but it should have
lost a little bit more speed at the end
here definitely but I'm yeah let's get
on board with the Train here the other
one that would be and go into the front
seat so here we've got that slow roll
which is a little bit jittery at the end
is not too much you can change about
this this roll is very smooth and going
down into this section here with a sort
of double up straight track section and
down into the helix over here which
another thing I just wanted to quickly
say is it's good to sometimes have your
coaster go underneath a section where
it's already been especially around
curves like that because hybrid coasters
like these are very often redone all the
older wooden coaster models so you'll
have to imagine that for this cause for
instance there used to be an old
opponent course that followed the same
layouts just didn't have the same
elements and it's just borrowing the
structure and the location from that and
in a similar way to wooden coasters that
means that we're also sharing the
supports which means that we're kind of
like reusing the same support structure
for the rest of the ride which is
something that's quite difficult wooden
coasters in that as a result you also
kind of see for
Coasters see how that basically it for
this tutorial if you have any general
questions or feedback or anything to say
about this feel free to shoot it in the
comment section and if it's anything
that I can improve upon or if there's
anything that you can give other people
tips about it's definitely something
that I'll want to return to in the
comment section as well so it's always
welcome and yep that's basically it for
this video so thank you guys for
watching and I'll see you guys in the
next episode of Dan Costa College